>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Tom Sherwood: Good afternoon
all you Book Festival folks.
I'm Tom Sherwood from
NBC4 here in Washington
and the public radio WAMU
Kojo Nnamdi Show on Fridays.
Thank you for being here.
You're welcome, your
cellphones are not.
But I always say, don't turn it
off, if it rings, we just want you
to put it on speaker phone so
we'll know who's calling you.
And by the way, this
is your legal warning.
Your presence here is your
permission to be videotaped
and quoted and misrepresented
on social media.
Now, finding your way around
this huge convention center,
it opened in 2003, can be daunting
going up and down floors in one room
and then another, finding
food, finding the bathrooms,
lining up for autographs.
You might say being here today
is "enjoyably exhaustive".
Enjoyably exhaustive, well,
that's the high praise
that New York Times' review gave to
Douglas Brinkley, his latest book
on American politics and
culture, "Rightful Heritage:
Franklin D. Roosevelt
and the Land of America".
I incidentally will
not be exhaustive.
In his nearly two dozen books
over 25 years, historian Brinkley,
not related to that other
guy, has rewalked and retraced
so many elements of America, our
wars, our politics, our industry,
our natural disaster called Katrina.
The light-- The Rice professor
especially has been honored
for his attention to Franklin D.
Roosevelt and Teddy Roosevelt.
So, it's fitting in this
year the 100th anniversary
of the National Park Service,
and not far from the FDR Memorial
and the Potomac River island
named in Teddy Roosevelt's honor.
Douglas Brinkley can help
us understand America.
In here, the nation's capital today,
as we celebrate this book festival,
as we open the new African-American
museum on the National Mall.
And yes, as we steal ourselves
for Monday night's, not football,
but presidential debate in
this difficult campaign year,
in these next few minutes, maybe
Douglas Brinkley can offer insight
and hope in this still
forming sweet land of liberty.
Please, everyone, welcome
Douglas Brinkley.
[ Applause ]
>> Douglas Brinkley: It is
wonderful to be introduced by Tom
who has an extraordinary
voice and so--
And I'm trying to-- I
try to modulate mine.
I'm used to talking loud because
I'm a Rice University professor.
You have to project
without microphones.
But I'm here to talk about Franklin
D. Roosevelt and the national parks.
FDR, we all know, is he was
called the squire of Hyde Park.
He was born in 1882 in
the Hudson River Valley.
And his whole life, the Hudson
became his sanctified landscape,
it's the place that he most loved.
He was born on Hyde Park on the
Hudson, he lived in the same home
where he was born all of his life
and he's buried at Hyde Park,
it's our nation's first
presidential library.
And he would always find strength
from that river 315 miles going
from the high Adirondack Mountains
coming in to New York City.
It is a spectacular river.
And when he was born in
1882, his family was part
of keeping the Hudson
beautiful movement.
Today, we call it the
Scenic Hudson movement.
But everybody was starting to look
at resources being
destroyed in the East Coast.
This is pre-- When he's born,
the idea that the [inaudible]
where you save national
forests in the east,
and everybody was clear-cutting
and the river was getting polluted
and fish stocks were dying.
And so, Franklin Roosevelt's
father became very popular
in local conservation on the Hudson.
And they're also the
number one book writer.
I'm at a book festival.
If you were alive in
1880s, 1890s, 1900,
the big writer was John
Burroughs, the great naturalist
who sanctified the Catskills.
And so, FDR grew up
conservation as we call today,
it was part of his life script, most
famously because Theodore Roosevelt,
his fifth cousin who he
nevertheless called uncle Teddy
or Uncle Theodore, he as
you know is synonymous
with the conservation
movement, Theodore Roosevelt.
And TR always enjoyed looking at,
from New York City,
but looking west.
FDR was more about the
oceans and the rivers.
But by the time Franklin Roosevelt
goes to college, to Harvard,
and you need to know if you want
to understand anything at all
about Franklin Roosevelt, you
have to study Theodore Roosevelt.
They-- He took as a model, you know,
Uncle Theodore's life
as sort of a script.
So, Theodore Roosevelt had
been the head of the Forest,
Fish and Game Commission
in New York State.
FDR becomes the head of it.
Theodore Roosevelt was the
assistant secretary of the navy.
FDR was the assistant
secretary of the navy.
Theodore Roosevelt was
governor of New York.
FDR was a governor of New York.
Theodore Roosevelt loved big navy.
FDR loved big navy.
Theodore Roosevelt
loved conservation
and the natural resources
and heirlooms of America.
FDR loved all of those.
Theodore Roosevelt had a
niece named Eleanor Roosevelt,
and FDR married her.
You cannot deal with all-- the
revolution of the New Deal years
in conservation and the Civilian
Conservation Corps and the like,
which I'm going to talk about in a
minute without thinking about TR.
But Theodore Roosevelt created two
mechanisms as president, guys, that,
you know, all national parks, we're
here celebrating the system was born
under the Organic Act in
1916 by Woodrow Wilson.
But that Organic Act for a national
park, it has to go through Congress.
So, Theodore Roosevelt as
president would do that.
From 1901 to 1909, he pushed
through Crater Lake in Oregon,
Mesa Verde in Colorado, Wind
Cave in South Dakota and others.
But Theodore Roosevelt as
president created two mechanisms
which all presidents
followed, have used,
and one is called national
monuments.
And the idea is built on
the Antiquities Act of 1906.
The Antiquities Act was an
elastic piece of legislation,
but instead for scientific reasons,
mainly meant for archeological digs
of prehistoric dinosaur bones
and for Native American relics
that a president could
declare, ward off an area,
think about like a murder site
with the yellow piece of plastic,
you know, going around, a
hunk of land that could be,
by executive order, saved.
And the reason this
Antiquities Act of 1906 went
into play is the Europeans
were robbing our western sites.
They recognized the importance
of the Navajo and the Apache
and the Plain Indians, and
they were stealing things.
And they were stealing
our dinosaur bones.
So, this gets passed on Congress.
Well, Theodore Roosevelt
ends up going to Yellowstone
with John Burroughs,
the great naturalist,
then he goes to the Grand Canyon.
And TR stands at that canyon, looks
out over the divine abyss and says,
do not touch it, God has made
it, you will only mar it,
leave the Grand Canyon alone.
And Congress and Senate starts
moving to perhaps mine it for zinc,
asbestos and copper, and Theodore
Roosevelt then uses the executive
order meant for smaller
parcels for over 600,000 acres.
And now, it's over a
million acres today
or else the Grand Canyon
would have been lost.
And TR would do that to save
the redwoods at Muir Woods.
He would do that, you know,
to save Devils Tower, Wyoming.
So, that lives on after--
due to Theodore Roosevelt.
Barack Obama is now the president
that assigned more national
monuments than any other.
I just wrote a piece about a week
ago in the New York Times about it.
Secondly, hundred years ago, women
here would have worn a bonnet
with ornamental feathers
to hear me speak.
You may not think you would have,
you may have-- but you would have.
And these would have been
feathers of an egret or a heron.
Nothing calls for federal action
more than bird protection.
You could not have a liberal
Connecticut Audubon Society that's
protecting the birds to
have them fly to Florida
and be slaughtered willy-nilly.
Birds know no boundaries.
So, it demanded federal
attention if we are going
to save species for extinction.
And Theodore Roosevelt goes
to Pelican Island, Florida,
a bird rookery where these
guys were coming with guns
and gunning all the birds
and plucking the feathers
and then stealing the eggs.
And he says, I so declare it
a federal bird reservation.
And he does that 51 times,
saving the albatross of Hawaii,
saving parts of Alaska
the size of West Virginia
and giving these areas to wildlife.
Those 51 are later expanded by
dozens to over 100 to 200 by FDR.
And it's Franklin Roosevelt
building on TR's bird reservations
that creates the 1940
today's US Fish and Wildlife.
You all, here in the audience, own
over 550 national wildlife refuges
because of TR starting
it and FDR moving on it.
And for those national monuments I
just mentioned, when you can't get
up a piece of land
saved through Congress,
you do the executive
order, so many places
that we all celebrate
in this country.
Capitol Reef in Utah, a great
national park, FDR creates it
as a monument, today, it's a park.
Channel Islands off of Santa
Barbara area in Ventura, California,
gorgeous islands, the
Galapagos of America,
FDR saves it as a national
monument, today, it's a park.
The Olympics National Forest
up there, beautiful rainforest
in Washington State, FDR went there
and saw how people were
recklessly clear-cutting the land.
And Franklin Roosevelt
said, whoever did that,
I hope they're roasting in hell.
And he pushes through the creation
of our Olympic National Park.
So-- But keep in mind, the monuments
and wildlife refuges
are both Roosevelt's.
But FDR takes it to a new level.
Now, the turning point for
Franklin Roosevelt I think
as a true conservationist to match
and perhaps supersede Theodore
is-- it occurs in 1921.
FDR is-- goes and he loses, we're
dealing in election right now.
In 1920, it was Warren
Harding beat Cox and Roosevelt.
FDR was the VP in 1920,
the Democrats lose.
FDR had no job.
He had been assistant
secretary of the navy.
He was just now the
losing VP candidate.
And he asked himself, what would
Theodore Roosevelt have done?
And the answer was, he worked for
the boy scouts of Greater New York.
TR was the great pusher of the
boy scouts, the godfather of it.
And now, Franklin Roosevelt
organizes the boy scouts
of Greater New York to go
to Bear Mountain State Park,
on the Hudson River, in
his backyard up there,
and bring all these inner city
kids to do horseshoes and archery
and fishing and enjoy the
bounties of nature in the Hudson.
And unfortunately, he went
swimming with these boy scouts
and we think there
contracted the poliovirus.
And he didn't manifest itself till
he got to Campobello, New Brunswick.
And while he was there, he
went to bed, he had sweats,
he didn't feel well and
he woke up with no feeling
in the lower half of his body.
The man you all know for
saying, "We have nothing to fear
but fear itself," you know, was
another fear and panic and terror.
Eleanor Roosevelt became
his Florence Nightingale.
It was very generous of her
because she had found love letters
from Lucy Mercer that
FDR was having an affair.
She put all that aside.
And he goes back to Hyde Park on
the Hudson to heal, and nobody wants
to see him because to hug somebody
with polio would have been a fear
if you would have contracted it.
So, all these friends,
Mr. good-looking,
Mr. assistant secretary of the navy,
Mr. I was just the VP
nominee is now a pariah.
And he found soulless on the Hudson
among the squirrels and the birds.
FDR was a lifelong ornithologist.
And then he says, what did
Theodore Roosevelt do in his crisis?
Theodore Roosevelt's
big crisis, guys,
was not when he was the Rough Rider
in 1898 in the Spanish-American War.
Theodore Roosevelt's big crisis
was when he got shot in 1912
in Milwaukee when he was delivering
a speech for the Bull Moose Party.
Theodore Roosevelt's huge crisis
came when he was a young man,
and on the same day,
Valentine's Day, he--
TR lost his mother
on the same house,
his mother with Bright's
disease, collapsed kidneys
and his wife died giving childbirth.
He lost his mom and his wife on
the same day, Theodore Roosevelt.
We, as scholars, read
people's mail for a living,
and there's nothing more moving
than seeing the giant X that TR puts
in his diary and says, the light
has gone out of my life forever.
What does he do when he's
depressed losing a mother and wife?
He got lost in the wild.
He went to North Dakota, the Dakota
Territory, Medora, the badlands,
went looking for grizzly
and buffalo.
In fact, he starts the modern
endangered species movement,
protection of North
American animal life.
When he kills a buffalo,
Theodore Roosevelt up there,
and then realizes they're all
disappearing and he creates Boone
and Crockett Club to save them.
So, FDR gets lost in the wilderness.
But he goes to the Everglades.
And Everglades is a national park
that Franklin Roosevelt creates.
But he goes in the Everglades
and the whole Florida Keys
and goes boating, and he thinks that
water will help him with the polio.
And he write-- He's down there
with an ornithologist friend
in the 1920s writing down all of
the different species he sees.
He's birdwatching and
trying to heal in nature,
the way TR had done in the badlands.
He comes back from these Florida
trips and buys Warm Springs,
Georgia, a resort of natural thermal
pools in Georgia, Meriwether County.
You can go there now, and he creates
a resort for people with polio,
living in nature among
the trees and the rest.
And that's his business, FDR.
And he becomes the leader
of the state park movement.
Do you guys realize that FDR in
the '20s is pushing state parks?
But by the time he's president,
the New Deal will create
over 800 state parks
in the United States.
States didn't even have state parks
until FDR's New Deal workforces came
and built them, including Texas
where I live and Austin and I teach
at Rice in Houston right now.
And he then decides, well, I'll
try to get back into politics, FDR,
and he trains to give a speech at
Madison Square Gardens for Al Smith,
the big shot in New York.
And his training isn't practicing
his verbiage, it's learning how
to lean on one son and move his hips
in a very painful motion
to get to the podium.
And everybody at Madison Square
Garden, when FDR came out,
held their breath, first off,
everybody thought he was done
with politics, he was too sick.
Here, you're just praying
he doesn't fall.
Then he got to the podium
and gave an amazing speech
and got a thunderous standing
ovation, off the charts.
It went on almost an hour.
Next days, New York Times says,
move over Al Smith, FDR is the man.
He's the hot guy in politics now.
And from that resurrection, FDR runs
for governor in 1928 of New York
and then governor in
1930, and he wins both.
And his big program is planting
trees, soil conservation,
reforestation because he was a
rural Upstate New York politician,
FDR, not a New York City guy.
I've read letters Franklin
Roosevelt would write, please,
do not say I'm from new York City.
His constituents were apple
growers and people growing orchids
and lumberers in the
Catskills and fishermen.
And he was a rural politician and
he worked as governor to pay men
with no jobs, unemployed,
homeless, essentially a dollar a day
to start tree planting
and building state parks
and restocking lakes and ponds.
Franklin Roosevelt's whole calling
card was conservation as governor.
So when you cut to 1932, when
he gives the New Deal speech
and you cut to Franklin Roosevelt
saying we're going to put people
to work, he, in his own mind,
creates the Civilian
Conservation Corps.
And not that only does
he beat Herbert Hoover,
but at his famous inaugural
weeks later,
he announces his pet New
Deal program, the CCC.
The CCC from 1933 to 1942,
plants around three billion trees
across the United States.
Because these-- These are
done by unemployed men.
Somebody from New York, New
Jersey suddenly finds himself
in Zion National Park in
Utah or somebody, you know,
from a poor neighborhood
of Philadelphia suddenly
on New Mexico-Arizona border.
It was remarkable and it worked.
And because the big
mistake we make is thinking
about the Great Depression
being Wall Street collapsed
and the financial markets
and bank foreclosures,
we had destroyed the
land of America.
We had done the great plow up in the
Midwest and chopped all the trees.
We had soils erosion, man-made
problems, environmental disaster
of the Dust Bowl in the 1930s.
We had drained wetlands,
we had drained swamps.
And so, it became absolute-- a
landscape of America that was dying.
And he takes it over and he
is able to, as president,
take TR conservation to a new level.
Do you want to know how
committed Franklin Roosevelt is
to our parks in the love of America?
Franklin Roosevelt at the
time of Pearl Harbor, Pearl--
this is a big moment of Pearl
Harbor, he gets a letter
from Rosalie Edge with
this great Harold Ickes,
the best interior secretary
in American history.
And Edge is a conservation
environmental activist
from New York.
And she says, dear Mr. President,
the trumpeter swan is going
to go extinct because you had
built a 10th mountain division,
a training facility for ski
troopers at Henrys Lake, Idaho.
And it happens to be that area
that the water doesn't freeze over,
so the trumpeters spend their
winters there instead of migrating.
And if you don't do something,
trumpeters can go extinct.
Well, the 10th mountain division
facility costs like $24 million.
It was training our
soldiers to go fight in Italy
and Germany and in Europe.
And FDR writes a moving
letter to his Secretary
of Defense Henry K. Stimson.
Dear Henry, I've now
found out about the flop
between the US army
and the trumpeters.
I've looked into it
and the verdict is in.
I side with the trumpeters.
The 10th mountain division
must re-nest.
Sincerely, Franklin D. Roosevelt.
Why at the time of Pearl
Harbor would he do that?
Well, who here doesn't want to
save trumpeter swans species, OK,
but this is the big crucible,
because he is telling the war
department, he need to write letters
like that to agriculture department
and to every division in government,
our public lands are
our inheritance.
We are not going to destroy
our national forests and parks
and monuments and state parks
by going in for win the war.
These are what we're fighting for.
Our public land system is what
America is about, it's our heritage,
hence why I call my
book Rightful Heritage,
that's what he would call all
of these recreation places
and special places we have.
He did something similar to save
the whooping crane from extinction
by signing an executive order
creating Aransas National Wildlife
Refuge in Texas, a national
park, guys, June 6, 1944, D-Day.
Do you realize on D-Day here in
Washington, Franklin Roosevelt,
when all the news was coming,
wouldn't cancel a meeting
about Big Bend National Park?
And he creates-- takes the land deed
for it on D-Day with Amon Carter
and people from Fort Worth.
Pictures on D-Day with maps that
he's picking out where the roads
and how one could bring
visitors to Big Bend.
He goes to Glacier National Park.
He makes them set up radio shop
there so he could stand with the CCC
and say, there is nothing more
American than our national parks.
In 1937, he traveled and
created Cape Hatteras,
our nation's first
national seashore,
creating a whole new designation.
John F. Kennedy was
very keen on that.
That's why Kennedy saved
Cape Cod National Seashore,
South Padre Island in Texas,
Point Reyes in California.
But little known is Roosevelt
would go all over on his yachts
and on navy ships, and he
disappeared on the eve really
of World War II in the
late 1930s to go disappear
into the Galapagos Islands.
FDR went for weeks doing
floral and fauna collections
for the Smithsonian Institute,
looking for new species
of burrowing shrimp and fish,
because this love of biology
and conservation is in the
Roosevelt's bloodstream.
I will end by telling you
two quick things, he's--
whenever Franklin Roosevelt
put on a form occupation,
he would write tree farmer.
He ran tree plantations at Warm
Springs, Georgia and on the Hudson.
If you go to his home, you will
see the forest, he planted it all.
That was-- When he would
bring Churchill to Hyde Park,
he was showing off the
forest that he planted
and how he was a scientific
forester.
It meant everything to him.
He had learned inside out
about soil conservation.
FDR thought that deforestation,
the killing of trees,
meant utter poverty.
So much so that the time of
Tehran Conference, he went over,
and of course was in the
Middle East, and he comes home
and writes a personal letter to
the shah of Iran and to the king
of Saudi Arabia saying, well, I've
been to your part of the world now,
and I've got to tell you,
you've got a forestry problem.
And I'm personally willing to loan
my time pro bono to help you fix it.
Do not feel bad, we have this
problem out of-- we have, you know,
the Dust Bowl, we know some of
that by figuring out ways to help.
Do you realize that in 1945, right
before his death, April 12, '45,
Franklin D. Roosevelt was
working with Gifford Pinchot,
the chief forester for Theodore
Roosevelt who's now in his 80s,
had a couple of heart attacks,
was going to be dead soon
and they conspired together to make
the founding of the United Nations,
a key principle was
going to be conservation
as a basis of permanent peace.
And FDR was moving to have
sharing of natural resources,
to have global pollution laws,
to have ways that we will
have international forestry
and wildlife protection laws.
Everybody at war and state
department went running,
they would ignore him.
And one of the few times I ever saw
FDR was angry when he wrote a letter
and was telling the state
department, I am serious about this,
conservation is going to
be a big part of the UN,
we're going to do global
conservation right off the bat.
When he died, a lot of this
energy of conservation died
with the Truman administration,
the Truman crowd had no interest.
But in the end, our heritage in
the United States of national parks
like the Smokies, the Everglades,
great roads like the Blue
Ridge Parkway and Natchez Trace
and magical parks like
Mammoth Cave in Kentucky,
Isle Royale in Michigan,
I can go on and on and on.
We owe it to Franklin D.
Roosevelt for their time of crisis
in the Great Depression of World
War I reminded us that stewardship
of our national resources was one
of if not the most important
thing that we can do.
Great countries take
care of their landscapes.
And Franklin Roosevelt in my
mind along with TR was one
of the two great conservation
presidents.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Doug, I have a comment
before I ask my question.
We just came back from Hyde Park
and you know that across the Hudson,
there is this walking bridge
called the FDR Bridge.
And I thought it was
because, you know,
he and Eleanor came from that area.
But now you're saying maybe
it was in tribute to the fact
that this is only bridge you can--
people can walk, no cars and--
>> Douglas Brinkley: Yes.
Yes, that's part of
why they've done that.
But across the river from Hyde Park,
his home, John Burroughs, this--
he's like John Muir, John Burroughs,
he's-- if-- we're a book crowd here.
Look up and read about John
Burroughs, he's very undersung.
He lived directly across
the street on the Hudson.
Then FDR would always have to go
on the other side of the Hudson.
And that bridge is a way to
kind of connect that region.
>> Right. All right.
Now, let me ask you
a technical question.
Going back to the relationship
between Teddy and Franklin, OK,
you know when Teddy was
police chief whatever,
he would walk in the streets
with newspaper people.
And he knew to use the newspapers
as a vehicle to communicate.
And you know many years later,
this guy, Franklin Roosevelt,
enhanced that to the radio.
So that was a big, big change.
>> Douglas Brinkley: Yeah.
Well, you're absolutely right.
TR was a genius at
manipulating cartoonist.
I mean, the teddy bear
toy grew out of his--
going on a bear hunt and he wouldn't
shoot the bear in Mississippi
and it became a symbol
for Fair Chase hunting
in conservation of
Theodore Roosevelt.
FDR used radio so effectively
to bring that voice
because he was incapacitated,
unable to walk.
But what's not known about Franklin
is he trained his upper body,
it was amazingly strong.
And he would go fishing all over.
He became a big buff
on marine conservation.
So, he would pull in Silver
Kings, giant tarpon and go
on these marine expeditions
because that was a way for him
to get outdoor recreation.
And it was also a way not to
have the press come with him
because his health was
deeply precarious at times.
So if he could get out at sea and go
to the Dry Tortugas which he saved
in Florida, FDR, and spend time
there, whenever he see a place
that he liked, he'd sign in an
executive order and save it.
It's really quite remarkable.
Thank you.
>> Yeah. Now let me
get to the point.
The-- Today with the press, you
see Trump, you see others saying,
as a president, I would
do this, I will do this,
a key point that when
Roosevelt, Franklin Roosevelt,
came in the office, he used the
term, let's try it, try it, try it.
Did he inherit that from Teddy?
>> Douglas Brinkley: I'll tell you,
I never quote Stalin in public,
but I'm going to do it,
for-- just for you guys.
Stalin used to say after
negotiating with Churchill and FDR,
Churchill will work with you
and then try to sneak his hand
in your pocket to steal a coin.
FDR smiles and greets you,
jams both hands in and pulls
out everything all at once.
It's very true, FDR
love-- so all of these.
You know, people-- when he try to
pack the Supreme Court for example,
people were all saying, oh, he-- in
1937, people were turning in FDR,
he was signing executive orders
left and right saving wild places
because nobody knew
what was going on.
Then he got revenge on that
by picking William O. Douglas,
the most environmental
conservation-driven person
of the '60s and '70s who saved
the C&O Canal incidentally here.
And it's-- And he put
him to the Supreme Court.
Also, to tell you, the mall
here that we're honoring
at the National Book
Festival, that's FDR.
Months after, he becomes president,
he grabs all of the monuments,
the mall, the White House and
puts it in to interior department.
They used to be run by
other war department.
Agriculture, he made it.
He built today's interior
department,
Franklin Roosevelt and Harold Ickes.
And now, our National Park
Service keeps growing,
and that's what FDR wanted,
like history to be part of it,
not just Yellowstone's
and Yosemite's.
So Barack Obama has just
signed an executive order
to do stonewall for LGBT history.
He just did-- Obama did Cesar Chavez
in California for Latino history.
He just did Harriet Tubman in
Maryland for Underground Railroad.
He's opening up the narrative as
they're saying of American history.
Obama has been great at that.
FDR is the one who started that
ability to save labor strike places
or something that wasn't-- you
know, might be controversial
and save those as part
of our national heritage.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Douglas Brinkley: Yes, sir.
>> I've had a chance
to read both your books
on Theodore Roosevelt
and Franklin Roosevelt.
Thank you, they are
absolute magnificent.
In reading them and in
listening to you today, you know,
I observed that we've got one
great Republican president
and one great Democratic president.
And for a long period
of time, conservation
and the environmental movement
wasn't really a partisan issue.
Now, it's a very deeply
partisan issue.
What happened?
>> Douglas Brinkley:
Amazing question.
And it used to be Republican Party
got into conservation all the time.
Many of the heroes, including
the Rockefeller family who--
incidentally who did Laurance
Rockefeller and John D. Jr. and the
like who did so much for it.
Ronald Reagan created
over 50 wilderness areas,
that's roadless areas of pristine
wilderness, Reagan did that.
Today, you have a Republican Party
that is running on oil, gas, oil,
gas, drill baby drill,
open, open, open.
And they-- There's a backlash
against the federal government,
particularly in the
Western Alaska that--
so it puts things at loggerheads.
So if you're a Republican
in the Senate today,
being a conservationist
is very, very hard.
The turning point in my mind was
when the word conservation
was replaced by environmental.
George McGovern told before he died,
I wish we would have just kept
the word conservation because I--
it sounds like conservative.
And I could push things
through in the Senate.
But once that word environment came,
it was tied up to the '60s cultural
wars of hippies and tree-huggers
and marijuana and, you
know, and it became seen
as like a left issue
in-- out of the '60s.
And we haven't fully
recovered with that.
However, there are Republican
congressmen like Congressman Simpson
from Idaho who recently just
saved Boulder-White Clouds
as a wilderness area.
And there are a few very-- Lamar
Alexander of Tennessee has gotten
and do the conservation
story quite a bit.
But unfortunately, like so much in
our culture, it's become partisan.
And I'm hoping that eventually,
it'll come back because if I go
to a group of conservatives,
Republicans somewhere and talk
about saving the local
lake or river,
they love me because I'm praising
local sites and we want it clean,
we want our kids to fish and hunt.
We-- But if I started dropping
the e-bomb environmental,
you'll lose half your
audience right now.
So, we've got to kind
of-- a lot of it might be
with the way we repackage
how we speak about it.
So, I'm-- But I-- It's
a frustration.
Barry Goldwater was a pretty
good conservationist actually.
>> Mr. Brinkley, I've read your book
on Teddy Roosevelt, looking forward
to read the book on FDR, huge fan.
>> Douglas Brinkley: Thank you.
>> Really appreciated
your lecture today.
I wanted to ask a question or
maybe get your thoughts on an issue
that is related to
the last question.
In the course of your
lecture and in your books,
you described the way the presidents
used their authority to create
and conserve these natural areas.
But it seems that overwhelmingly,
they relied upon the power
of executive orders or unilateral
executive branch authority
and particularly relying, I think,
it was on the Antiquities Act
which authorizes the president
to apply that authority
without consulting or getting
the approval of Congress.
And it's my amateur observation
that over the decades,
the fact that these
conservation efforts took place
through presidential authority
and many instances bypassing
local congressional delegations
without seeking the
support of Congress,
without needing the support of
Congress, created a situation
that has presented
challenges in the modern era.
And I recognized that the presidents
needed to do what they needed to do.
And I certainly approve
of what they did.
I love the result.
But we have, in your
view, created something
of a federalist problem
in terms of--
>> Douglas Brinkley: Well, there is.
>> -- this backlash of this
assertion of federal authority.
>> Douglas Brinkley: OK.
I went to the national monuments
to keep in on FDR a little.
FDR, for example, in the
middle of World War II was--
gifted Jackson Hole,
Wyoming and wrote--
The Rockefellers bought
all these land up.
Now, they're giving it to him.
FDR signs an executive order saying,
we're going to create the Grand--
save the Grand Teton, Jackson Hole.
You should read what
happened to FDR.
You're a Hitler, you're land
grabbing, the federal government--
There's nobody today that doesn't
want Jackson Hole protected
like FDR did.
They were in California, in
Joshua Tree, that's FDR's.
A woman named Minerva Hamilton
Hoyt was trying to get it
as a park through--
Congress said it's desert.
Deserts are wasteland,
nobody wants it.
And she was a botanist and saying,
no, these Joshua Trees are amazing.
Meanwhile, the kids that go
out to Burning Man used to go
out on the desert and pour
gasoline and burn the Joshuas
because they shoot up
like a torch to the night.
And they would look for the
biggest and they burn them all.
So, she eventually gets to
FDR and says, can you save it?
And he looks at her plan and
says, [inaudible] a million acres.
And she said, well, the
railroads have interest there
and the local miners.
He said, lawyers will
figure it out later.
We're going to do it.
She was stunned, she got
what she wanted from him.
In Kings Canyon, another national
park of FDR's in California,
it took-- a young unknown
photographer named Ansel Adams took
these photos.
And Eleanor Roosevelt said,
if you want my husband
to save something, bring the photos.
He's a sucker for,
well, Adams' photos.
So, he ended up seeing these
and pushed to save Kings Canyon.
But FDR didn't like that it was
going to be roadless, no roads,
and he said, I'm never going to
be able to go see it, that area.
Because if there are no roads and
visitor lookouts, I won't be able
to go because of my thing, but he
did it anyway because you just have
to have a strong president
to do it or else--
or, you know, I've been
for example to Haiti.
You want to fly over Hispaniola,
look at Dominican Republic
with forest and Haiti deforested.
I need you all to believe that
in the 1930s and early '40s,
our country was in genuinely awful
shape, in swamps, arctic tundra,
deserts were not considered
ecosystems worth saving.
To now, these places are
the big economic engines.
Joshua Tree doesn't know
what to do with visitors.
It's so overcrowded.
So, the Antiquities Act
gives presidents a mechanism.
And George W. Bush
signed a giant one
out in the Hawaii for a marine area.
Calvin Coolidge used to
sign them all the time.
I'm just suggesting, it's--
that has become bipartisan,
monuments, presidents will do them.
But Obama just did the Maine
woods, Katahdi, a couple weeks ago,
and they're angry in Maine about
it, even though the land was gifted
by Roxanne Quimby who founded
Burt's Bees, the women's product.
She became the biggest
land owner in Maine, said,
I'll not only give you the land to
the federal government as a park,
but I'll also endow
it with $20 million.
And the conservatives
in Maine don't want it.
They see it as federal government
intrusion into their lives.
So, the good news here, and
I'll-- I think I better end,
the national parks on
their centennial right now
are spectacular.
We need to love them
more, visit them.
They really are this great
gift and we owe both Theodore
and Franklin Roosevelt a huge bit
of credit for being visionaries,
of making our country
something special.
Without it, we would be strip
malls and superhighways.
But by saving all these wild places,
it's kept the essential spirit
of America in my mind alive.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.